[Music]
[Applause]
this is what the world has come to
expect from australia
voted one of the greatest pyrotechnic
shows on earth
but the upcoming new year's eve
fireworks spectacular was almost snuffed
out
fresh outbreaks of coronavirus forcing
new lockdowns
in the same way last year when we had
the bushfires there was a call to cancel
the fireworks for exactly
you know similar kinds of reasons not so
much that you couldn't gather on the
harbour's edge but
was it appropriate and overwhelming the
feedback that we got from a lot of
regional communities was
no we need those fireworks to be there
it's a sign of normality it's a sign of
hope they need to happen
final preparations and last minute
checks to ensure the show goes on
without a hitch
the foti family has been putting on
fireworks displays
since 1793 more than 20 in sydney
but this year's show will be cut back to
just
seven minutes it's more of an intimate
display
but the intensity i would say would
probably be more than what it's been in
previous years
ordinarily viewing areas just like this
would already be jam-packed
but not in a covered year the one to one
and a half
million people who cram every spare inch
of the sydney harbour foreshore to watch
the fireworks
are this year banned that means sydney
ciders
like the rest of the world will have to
watch their fireworks
on television miles and miles of high
stool barricades block any access to the
viewing areas
right across the city people living on
the harbour
will have a bird's eye view but they're
virtually the only ones
still tourism leaders already seeing
four billion dollars lost
every month hope tonight's fireworks are
the first steps
towards financial recovery from this
worldwide epidemic
little wonder these fireworks are seen
as such a sign of hope
david richardson sky news australia